او هل ستنتظرون حتى توافق روسيا على منحه
الحق في الحصول على الزياره القنصليه
ثانيا حدث تبادل للسفره مؤخرا
معتقلين امريكي هل يمكن للروسيا ان تبادل
الصحفي
وبطبيعه الحال هناك سابقه الان فرضاها
خصومنا للحصول على تبادل السجن شكرا شكرا
جزيلا لك
بدايه سمعتيني اقول هذا الكلام من قبل من
منظور الشخصي ومنظور وزاره الخارجيه ليس
هناك اي اهميه اكبر من امن الامريكيين في
العالم وهذا يشمل اولئك الذين يتم
اعتقالهم بطريقه ظالمه او يختطفون ويمنعون
من العوده الى وطنهم
والالتحاق باسرهم فيما يتعلقوا بايف ن
نحن نعمل من خلال التركيز على الاعتقال
الظالم وهناك عمليه نتبعها
ولكن
بالتاكيد نحاول ان نسرع الخطى قدر
المستطاع وسترك هذه العمليه تاخذ مجراها
انا شخصيا لا شك بانه اعتقل بطريقه ظلمه
من قبل روسيا وهذا تحديدا ما قلته لوزير
الخارجيه عندما تحدثت اليه خلال هذا
الاسبوع واكدت انه يجب اطلاقه فورا
ولكن اريد ان اتاكد هذا ما فعلته دائما
انه هناك طبعا اجراءات رسميه نتبعها وهذا
ما سنفعله
واتوقع ان تنتهي هذه الاجراءات قريبا بشكل
اوسع عندما يتعلق الامر اولا
وكما قلت من قبل
هذا المقترح الموجود على الطاوله منذ شهور
وسددته لوزير الخارجي من روسيا عليها ان
تحرج التقدم بشان هذا المقترح لسعاده بول
الى ارض الوطن وفي كلتا الحالتين
تمت
موازنه بين اعاده في المواطنين الى الوطن
وما يجب القيام به لتحقيق ذلك واعتقد وكما
اظهرنا ذلك في السابق والنتيجه كذلك
للتشريعات الموجوده لدينا اضافه الى ادوات
اخرى حتى عندما
نبذول الج بسعاده مواطنين وعادتهم الوطن
نريد ان نزيد الضغوط
والعقوبات على اولئك الذين يقومون بعمليه
اعتقال ظالم للمواطنين الامريكيين وهذا ما
قمنا به ونعمل ايضا على تنفيذ قانون روبرت
لي
اعطي الكلمه الان الى الممثل فريدوم
لدي سؤال السيد بالامس وزير خارجي
اوكرانيا قال بعد لقائه